et au Pays-Bas et au-delà des chiffres
il y a l'impact psychologique de cette
mesure si elle est appliquée ce serait
un coup d'arrêt à un mouvementue de
réduction du temps de travail depuis
plus d'un siècle Martin goues les
vacances payées accordées par notre
gouvernement ont rendu cette année au
plage de France toute leur animation
d'autrefis 1936 2 semaines de congé payé
le symbole de la réduction du temps de
travail depuis le début du siècle on
travaille de moins en moins mais il
faudra attendre 1956 pour la 3 semaine
et 1968 pour la 4e semaine de congé pay
face à la vague du chômage partager le
travail en travaill en moins est une
revendication des partis de gauche dès
qu'ils arrivent au pouvoir ils octroient
la 5è semaine de congé et les
39h 15 ans plus tard nouvelle alternance
politique les Français découvrent les
RTT départ c'était tellement trop trop
de jours de congé finalement d'un seul
coup que je me disais mais qu'est-ce que
je vais pouvoir en faire et aujourd'hui
je me pose absolument plus la la
question la réduction du temps de
travail qui a marqué le 20e siècle
pourrait aujourd'hui
ralentir ce qui sera la caractéristique
des prochaines années c'est pas une
réduction du temps de travail c'est une
variation une diversification des temps
de travail autrefois il y a encore 20
ans tout le monde faisait 9h m 2h 6h ou
bien 8h 17h tous les jours c'était très
régulier bon c'est devenu irrégulier
c'est devenu flexible dès son retour au
pouvoir l'année dernière la
droiteutorise semaine des 39h et demande
aux Français de travailler plus
longtemps pour financer leur retraite le
temps de travail est décidément un enjeu
politique je conç un dernier mot enfin
pour vous rappeler ce